share spotify with joe rogan
neil young says hell no dan
yeah thank you yes his songs used to be
groovy but now he wants them remove feed
okay
true he used to have a heart of gold but
now he sounds cranky and old that one
worked neil young says he wants his
music pulled off spotify because the
company is providing a platform for joe
rogan
that's the rock and roll spirit in an
open letter who does that to his
managers in record label i do not
probably written with a quill pen the
184 year old rocker wrote quote i am
doing this because spotify is spreading
fake information about vaccines what is
this mac what is this accent potentially
causing death to those who believe the
disinformation being spread by them i
want you to let spotify know immediately
today that i want all my music off their
platform they can have rogan or young
not both
maybe it's me but that's an easy choice
rogan of course has become a target
during the pandemic for his views of the
vaccine and how he treated his own covet
diagnosis of course neil young was in a
band with david crosby who freebased
every drug that wasn't ivor mechton
and it's not the first time young has
whined to spotify in 2019 he removed
most of his songs from the platform
claiming their sound quality wasn't good
enough before ultimately relenting and
letting them carry his music
so maybe it wasn't spotify's fault maybe
the songs aren't that good let's have a
quick refresher of young's biggest hit
[Music]
now i'm the old one now and you know
it's true
that was pretty good actually uh cat
what happened
to the radical artists now they're not
distinguishable from the man you have
people like
whoopi and neil young and
whoopi i'm already got two examples i'm
leaving one out yeah you need to use
three or no one you don't have a point i
know
everybody knows that springsteen yeah
there you go i'm not sure well with neil
young particularly i'm just confused
like who does he think his fans are
right like i don't think it's like you
know purple-haired socialists like bump
in buffalo springfield i don't think
that like every neil young fan that i
know has like at least seven guns right
uh but again it's open letter
it's not oh everyone can read this and
open letters everyone please read this
look at me yes so if you ever haven't in
general there might be exceptions um if
you ever there's an open letter i'm
gonna be like nah
i'd already know if i shouldn't he
paints people into a corner because
you're doing it publicly as opposed to a
private letter tyrus
neil young is now like mr roper
he's like oh yeah well and you know what
happened mr roper we got mr furley yeah
so uh you know what right i hope they
have an open response
that says fine yeah because
or i can't remember the last time i was
like online going where's my neil young
fix where's neil where's neil young
rogan has become an american institution
so
yeah yeah that's like me saying walking
into fox tomorrow and going listen one
of the murdock's got to go yeah
okay
rupert's gone it's tyrus time yeah i'll
wait it's why he clears out his stuff
yeah yeah yeah how do you think and i'm
gonna do it in an open statement
you would win and then it will please
there will be a closed door behind me
the locks change and my relationship
with security would significantly change
it's yes so you know yeah they won't be
high-fiving you or fist-bumping no
they'll say i miss you yes
don't call me yes
ari i think you uh you grew up in the
70s isn't neil young really a poor man's
gordon lightfoot
oh that's very mean to gordon lightfoot
yes um look
think about this when you're a rock and
roller you're so kind of supposed to be
open-minded you know free thinking and
here he is being a scold and telling
people off the air yeah
what has happened to all of us what is
going on with this you know part of it
is the pandemic everybody is so fed up
but it's this it's this
i hate to use these words but it's the
whole woke everything
if you don't agree with me if you say
what you say you don't have a right to
say it anymore and i used to admire the
old aclu when you stood up for actual
pure
speech nobody said because i disagree
with you i'm taking you off the air
yeah neil young that's what he wants
they need like somebody has to start an
organization called the new aclu
right
n-a-c-l-u neckloo right you're not even
listening and
you said new aclu
exactly by the way very advertent of you
that was a very yes do you know um do
you know who went to my high school
graduation i have no idea
well what's this topic about neil neil
young came to my high school graduation
young was there yes because he was
married to my friend's sister and he
showed up and he was at my high school
graduation what year was that is that
why we're doing this segment yes
did he say something mean to you no
you've been harboring a grudge for
decades 1983 i believe your moment has
arrived to get him i don't know anymore
i guess i ran out of questions
did he try to take you off the air no he
didn't he was very polite not yet not
yet after he watches this what are you
you got to respect spotify they they
don't they're they're sticking by and i
think that's actually i think that neil
young has since kind of backed away
because he saw that was stupid well also
i don't think that an open letter is how
you actually achieve the goal it's more
of a signal hey everyone this is what i
believe but he has no intention of it
actually happening and of course spotify
is going to stand behind rogan i
shouldn't say of course in our crazy
times but it's a good business decision
for them i think we can all agree also i
was hoping you would do the rest of the
segment in that accent
was i was transfixed by that i don't
know where i was going with that i was
trying to do somebody from the 1800s and
then i just immediately just went into
some kind of cocky british thing i'm not
necessarily known for my accent my
accents i'm more of an improv guy no
okay i'm not touching that one
that's a bear trap it is a bear trap
yeah i wish i had a bear trap
[Music]
there we go
you know what a bear trap is it's my
apartment down yeah there you go all
right come in they never leave they've
never heard so that's your type yeah the
only problem
the only problem is the drinks thank you
for encouraging him you stupid son of a
[ __ ]
trying to get those
i gotta use a lot of drano on those
clogs can we go to commercial yes
up next does a mask mandate get excused
when you compare them to children's
shoes
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else